welcome to this video were 15 minute
game against lily-livered lily-livered
from from the UK no name done yup place
5 15 minute regularly but never never
against me it seems ok ok i don't i am
not really don't really know the sukoon
thoughts on going for Kings Indian type
of position ok yeah I guess g3 I mostly
have played with c5 and sometimes with
d5 ok so we get a bit noni
yeah I don't really like it to play
without and I mean I prefer the modern
benoni type of structure here to regular
benoni what how did I was this plague
junk I don't really know that too well I
guess with a 6cm I only know vaguely the
sound plus a game kasparov with black
against scorch live from the Olympiad
1982 like a spiral played with 97 95 and
so on but I don't don't know the exact
order of this I'm not sure what why this
doing now I mean maybe 92 this rupee
eight sort of intends to play 94 so it's
maybe an idea to be able to cover that
Bishop f4 is still still would have been
an alternative I think now probably a
four well now i think this this might be
a theoretical line
94 I think that's 9485 and that's not be
six are interesting
yeah it's very that's very often a
useful after Knight e5 white pushes
afford this is entirely pointless so I
go through p8 I think an important thing
is that after night c4 here I ft 6
attack so I must I must attend to that I
think we are maybe really following this
X power of game maybe by transposition
another trick is they let c4b 5a bab
Knight a5 yeah this is one important the
idea so that the night comes to see 6b
five is entirely unplayable and d6 hangs
okay so the other thing is after night
c4 if I play Knight b6 white still can
take d 696 26 Bishop f4 and b 8 is gone
the rook so I cannot play Knight b6 so I
must play 95 there's no other way really
to to secure on the d6 bomb hmm yeah
they're really following this game night
a three now we are getting getting close
to it night a three and then I believe
not sure my dh5 i think was played it
all boiled down to a piece sacrifice
it's a very spectacular game the
psycho's power off against with like
Korchnoi Kasparov maybe I should do a
video on that but it's one of the most
complicated case i ever saw so it's a
very tricky to make a video on that game
that is not like more than one hour long
or you simply don't touch even the
surface okay what now the problem is if
I go let's say Bishop d7 e + f4 man i
distract this is not what I want want to
do I think I really think this node h5
they are very wacky ideas here like
night h5 g4 Queen h4 and stuff like that
that's really on I don't really see well
I cannot go Bishop d7 ham and force
coming I cannot play b5 ok let's let's
do that
it also gets f5 into the mix and i think
that the Kasparov game it continued with
AE for here efore rook e8 King h2 f5f
for and then Bishop d7 or something like
that it was completely bonkers I know I
really attached to this game I will I
will feature this this game so watch out
for that yeah I wonder what what is
going to do now maybe look up the theory
it is all discussed at length in known
in the Boris of rock d for repertoire
series book so if I would ever would be
playing unfair i would go to my
bookshelf behind me and grab this book
yeah it's a wide repertoire though so he
thinks that this is quite okay for white
but I remember remember that the lines
were really a yeah exceptionally
complicated so let's see yeah i mean if
you if you don't know the position you
have many things to think about like g4
here for example after which I really
think I play Queen age for I think this
is the right one it threatens Bishop g4
instantly and if white takes on h5 i
take on age three this really looks like
a dangerous attack note that white has
invested lots of time with the night
which is now on a three and
their form action on the King side is
not not illogical at all I mean look at
there's only the bishop on g2 covering
the king the Dwight is obviously not
really following theoretical knowledge
or even looking looking things up once
in a while I really think people look
the line up in 15 minute games sometimes
they have the time to grab the book from
there shall set and check what's what's
right or even maybe a consult the
database I mean if you want there there
are many ways to to cheat at chess yeah
i think ii for is really the move that
was played if white goes at for here
there's the choice i can move the night
just to d7 of course or i can i can take
on d3 which is I think what I will do if
it happens take g3 fe5 taker f1 this
should be a good a good deal for black I
get to the rook for for the Knights but
in the process I have completely wrecked
white skin side I don't really think
that f4 is good yeah well if I one idea
of Avoyelles I believe that f5 then
maybe can be taken on f5 Bishop f5 and
g4 I think after f4 after a four because
our are really played rook f8 somehow to
to to prepare that
efore look f8 and what then did he play
a form and I getting King h2 at five F
for something like that and then
Kasparov just just sacrificed the night
only five and white is investing tons of
time here it's not a disconnection right
no problem th2 yeah that's some more of
a safe move okay the question is yeah
well not really I probably have to play
at five anyway otherwise this doesn't
make much sense at all the question is
if he goes at for what am i doing do I
have a do have an aggressive move or do
I need to just retreat it and I said
something else entirely well G 4 I can
just sacrifice on g4 this is clear with
the bishop but FYI am f form
I don't really see a way to make a
sacrifice out of this somehow Oh Kayla
so let's go at five after f4 I have that
night f7 for the night which is not such
a terrible place I mean I know it's
looking at a five and g5 which is
covered but it protects d6 give some
shield for the king and yeah this was
clear 11 idea that white has in this
position I thought I could not take I
take and after night takes I have be
five I have be five anyway okay so be
five now right if I'm allowed to play
that I probably should play it or is
there some some other idea mall Knight
f6 s very logical move the night on h5
is offside but okay b5 it should be
should be okay i mean it it makes sure
that the night only three is not coming
to see form quickly
learn why disinvesting really a boatload
of time IAM five minutes don't owe him
five minute ahead on the clock in the
skin so unheard of
yeah I don't really like White's
position to be honest the bishop on see
one cannot move my bishop on g7 is
really a great piece night I'm not
positive at our what white what white
should do here maybe one way is to just
prepare the the bishop development so
Queen situ or something but where should
the bishop go we even on c1 yeah I
should white try to to improve the light
on a three which was certainly not a bad
idea it's really a terrible piece
m-maybe white can try to prepare the
before advance like rook b18b form this
is sometimes a good counter to the b5
play okay I could place you for him with
the temple no it's not it's not really
leading to much okay beehive as a text
this is something to to remember
okay let's let's not spend spend ages on
that the Queen does not really have
great square cell went all the way back
so what's what's next let's do that if I
can get rid of this eve all night it's
certainly a good idea the night on h5 is
not doing much anyway and takes Queen
takes even gets the Queen into play and
next idea would be bishop at 52 d 3
how I'd wife is really taking it to it
to extremes with the time the time usage
yeah I understand you don't want to take
and give me that activity but it's not
especially great on f to the snide okay
let's see I cannot go to d3 Bishop f5 d3
would be quite a natural follow-up so
maybe I should just shuffle the night
over here to see five
no that's probably probably not bad
let's do that it also gets my bishop
just have an active again so that the
night the bishop on c1 cannot easily
move yes and now to c5 ah night before
he's got my that's bad I was only
thinking about Knight d4 which is not
good
mmm wow that was that that was bad play
that was badly 97 was bad
yeah that helps wide enormously night to
be formed okay let's see can I what can
I do to to repair this I could play
before simply just push it but then
that's not default the six the c6 square
off the ester is the real issue maybe I
just I just need to allow it I mean more
what what it's maybe not Terrell I mean
knight on c6 it's not like I'm resigning
instantly whether this wasn't on at all
I thought I can take n play Knight be
three winning the rook and we're not
winning the look and maybe I'm just
winning the exchange yeah whatever I'll
take it Queen a 70 s may be limiting it
to two just giving away in exchange the
only way to cover the rook
okay is this some something something
else Seattle I take it let's just take
it and now it's an exchange but it's not
not so clear-cut because of the dark
squares an ID for and moves like that
look I can be threatening maybe rookie 7
numb now so that 94 I can can just take
maybe rookie to hear queen bee six now
intending before and okay just capturing
on f2 of course yeah this is really no
brainer I must take that and now just
before or is there something else before
now okay sure yeah I must go here not
much else mmm ma'am you have just taking
g for white white white there's no way
to defend it really they can play a king
g to but i can i can take on g2 then
look g2 kingi too noisy for attacking
the bishop and threatening 93
threatening rookie to that's that's
winning
yeah I think that's it this is the
easiest and then 94 yeah the bishop has
no squares I mean where where is it
going at this rookie to went everything
93
yeah okay to is the the worst part
didn't even consider but yeah that's
this one check so this is made check
checkmate yes was the kind of game that
makes you want to play the modern benoni
if it if it's working out it can lead to
and fantastic games where you I mean not
not a fantastically this wasn't a
fantastic game but I need leads to very
active position types where you can
really do something I mean I mean
probably here probably around here
there's the the theoretical theoretical
issue I can
I can should really look that up but
let's just say watch out for the courts
knowledge is power off game that I'm
going to cover so that you will see the
details about this you play teenage to
or she you never know I mean and around
here I already really like l'exposition
it's it's not easy for y2 to make this
an ammonia set up this is what I was
tried and I mean this just looks like
like a very good position this is
probably not helping but it's it's not
clear what what white should do here
maybe a night situ after all activating
the night but the way I where is it
going this just looks like a great
position to be honest here this is this
is really this was bad i mean 97 was bad
the idea wasn't so bad but it's just not
not working out correctly computer wants
to play hmm the simple probably
intending to play before him yeah now
that's just just excellent yeah just
excellent and the problem is that here
here of course he must go to be four and
not to deform this now i need to i need
to really yeah sort of win again i mean
it's not clear what what's going on the
knight on c6 is a real annoyance I was
actually intending to to play a move
like queen of 6cm this was my idea yeah
but that's it's not not not clear error
or this position and he must do that i
mean it's clear and this is just just
losing out right it's it's just not
enough for the for the exchange okay my
my king position is weakened but they
are not they are not enough attacking
pieces around yeah this is just just
flat out flat out winning it's probably
a force made already computers on minus
nine yeah this was some very good
position right out of the opening okay
watch out for the promised game that I'm
covering coach norv Kasparov thanks for
watching